the Florida man was finally solved after
nearly two decades Mike Williams
disappeared while on a hunting trip in
2000 his wife Denise led a massive
search for him then community members
concluded an alligator had killed him
but in December 2017 new conflicting
information emerged that changed
everything
48 hours correspondent Richard
Schlesinger gives us a look at this
week's edition of the broadcast 17 and a
half years we have always talked about
Mike Williams being missing not ever
finding his body not ever having
resolution was very difficult Mike
Williams vanished just one day before
his sixth wedding anniversary he met his
wife Denise at North Florida Christian
high school he was a football player she
was a cheerleader
there they were this like seemingly very
perfect couple with this very promising
life ahead of them Jennifer Portman is
the news director for the Tallahassee
Democrat and a consultant for 48 hours
they were gonna be celebrating their
wedding anniversary and so when he did
not come home about noon when he was
supposed to Denise started getting
worried and started calling around those
calls launched a six-week manhunt law
enforcement and friends and family
combing the lake looking for me they
found the boat his truck the trailer
that was all there
but searchers found no trace of Mike
Williams I got up in the helicopter one
of the things that I noticed there were
very large alligators swimming all
around this area people are attacked by
alligators little dogs are eaten by
alligators but you never hear of someone
who's just vanished eaten whole by an
alligator
that's what you believed happened to
Mike yes I firmly believe that but
Mike's mother Cheryl wasn't buying it
she never ever believed that her son was
in the lac she'd make picket signs there
were billboards you know have you seen
my son
she wrote the governor a letter every
day for nine years until God tells me in
my heart if that child is dead I cannot
give up looking for him he didn't just
fall out of the boat
this wasn't just a hunting accident it
is totally impossible for 185-pound man
to be consumed by an alligator without a
trace this man was murdered and they
blamed it on alligators for 17 years
sounds like Michael's mom never gave up
that search no messenger joins us now
she didn't seem to buy that argument she
didn't from day one and she let
everybody know it she we talked about
the letter she wrote you know how many
she wrote how many fourteen hundred and
seventy two that we were able to find
and what was the community's response to
her well you know it was a little rough
I mean they a lot of people thought she
was frankly nuts a lot of people thought
she just couldn't give it up that she
couldn't accept reality because that's a
good kind of genius blame it on the
alligator and they can't talk thank you
Richard
you can watch Richards full report is
called cold-blooded killer that's
tomorrow night after the Fitbit alibi
I love these titles it's part of a 48
hours double feature that starts at 9:00
8:00 central right here on CBS